because I would love to try and stand up
I'd love to do stand up I think you'd be
good I think you'll be good you say that
but when I try and write a joke I get I
get the opening bit I say that's a funny
idea Madonna's got divorced and I think
yeah where's my right you know I don't
well yeah I
never knew you were this weird really
you can't do it together for a couple of
days I know absolutely mental
in a nice way yeah yeah yeah but so
if you do win an award tonight
don't use it as a platform to make a
political speech right you're in no
position to lecture the public about
anything you know nothing about the real
world most of you spent less time in
school than Greta thundberg so if you
win right come up except your little
award thank your agent and your God
so
oh no no funny business there you go not
on this show
oh no it's a joke
that's a joke
what are you wearing
it's already turned up in a gray
something they wouldn't even have in TK
Maxx look at it
how much time you spin in London I know
you got a house here how much time you
spend here how much time you spend in
London well between the two probably a
bit more in London but you know yeah I
like I like to come here as often as I
can I heard the taxes bloody awful in
London
um in England is it just crazy well I'm
like you I like paying tax because it's
giving something back
stop all the sudden say chill bro
sorry sorry uh sorry
um yeah you're not you're still you're
not giving them you know they come out
they Park their cars they've got babies
that they haven't paid why would you
that'd be mental but
if I was you I'd be going thank you so
much these people and giving them you
know what I mean a new series of extras
starts this week uh congratulations on
well on getting a second series
essentially but also
congratulations on already [ __ ] up
it's next week you [ __ ]
[Applause]
I was sorry it was um I mean you know
you didn't write it and that's but do it
like but
do it like it's your do it like you were
clever enough to come up with this joke
yourself okay
[Applause]
into the Achilles heel of everybody like
when you tell a woman who's you know
that her that it's you know she looks
old that just hits a woman deep in it
which I think you said something about
the Sex and the City women like about
right it was airbrushed and I said we
know we know how old you are girls I saw
one of you in an episode of Bonanza
no I was saying why lie there's no
there's nothing wrong with being 50 or
looking 50.
is the star of the hilarious comedy the
Martian
I nearly died right
he's also the only person who Ben
Affleck hasn't been unfaithful to please
Welcome Matt Damon
[Applause]
thank you
um
foreign
I've only got a day to live and I said
what do you want to do
and then and then when that didn't
happen what is it yeah and then when
that thing happened Make A Wish
Foundation I'd like to go on Jimmy
Fallon please
and so you know that's not what you said
no no I didn't yeah you want to do
something else and then I said anything
but Jimmy
[Applause]
it's worked together do you ever go on
holiday together
can you imagine that oh it would be
horrible just think of the pictures me
looking pretty cool and sort of tired
and the thing naked he looks like one of
those baby fish you can actually see
through his body
you're one of about five people that
have been invited round my house I'm a
very sort of private person apart from
like you know Workman and Postman
um and uh they make me feel special yeah
rounding
refuge collector at least they're useful
yeah
I can't believe this uh you had a
birthday and is it 50 years old you're
not 50 years old are you really 50 50.
yeah I mean you look tremendous
you look like you're 35 if somebody had
to say to me uh how old I said the 35 a
35 honestly you look exactly like you
did the first except you're in better
shape remember you used to come out your
sort of pear-shaped when you come out
now you look great
if you looked you didn't say that at the
time though oh I didn't know I didn't
know what to think well no he said oh
you look good now because I looked awful
before that's all you're saying I needed
you to say it before you've got your
pear-shaped I'd have worked out faster
but now but but how how do you feel at
50 good right oh yeah
I'm grumpier I think I'm grumpier
grumpier yeah yeah I understand you a
lot more now I picked it on me no
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so about our next two presenters
the first is an actor producer writer
and director whose movies have grossed
over three and a half billion dollars at
the box office he's won two Academy
Awards and three Golden Globes for his
powerful and varied performances
starring in such films as Philadelphia
Forrest Gump Castaway Apollo 13 and
Saving Private Ryan
the other
is Tim Allen
well you know like like many of you we
recall back when Ricky Gervais was a
slightly chubby but very kind comedian
yeah
neither of which is he now
mainly Star Trek memorabilia because I
love Star Trek
no I've never been in a Star Trek but I
love the Original Series so I have like
I have the Gorn head from the original
series from the episode Arena where
I know I know
oh my God
every time you're on the program I try
to do this and it's always comes out
very clumsy let me try it one more time
possibly the best television show ever
what do you think
oh possibly what do you mean
what have you named your private parts
Pamela
thanks presenter
is the Queen of Pop
not you out and sit down this is
she's all woman I'll give you some Clues
she's always Vogue
she's a material girl and she's just
like a virgin
please welcome Madonna
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if I'm still
Just Like a Virgin Ricky
then why don't you come over here and do
something about it
I haven't kissed a girl in a few years
on TV
[Applause]
reminds me of some of great work that's
been done this year by cosmetic surgeons
um
it's an honor to be here um in a room
full of what I consider to be the most
important people on the planet actors
they're just they're just better than
ordinary people aren't they that's no we
all know that
um
imagine a world without actors oh God it
doesn't bear think about it imagine if I
ever went on strike oh what would we do
you couldn't replace them you couldn't
replace them with any other profession
lawyers or doctors can you imagine a
real surgeon doing what Hugh Laurie does
in-house it would be pathetic it'd be
all over the place we go no where do I
stand how's my American accent what
what's my lines you know Hugh with the
aid of coaches that could eventually
learn these lines while saving lives
he's a genius
how could you replace Kiefer Sutherland
in 24 I'd love to see a real
anti-terrorist agent try and defuse a
bomb in a busy train station in one hour
some of those scenes by the way where
Kiefer grabs on and beats him to a pulp
they weren't even in the script
um
the director just said keep rolling
we're working into the
actors aren't just loved here in
Hollywood they are loved the world over
because they're recognizable you can be
any you could be in the third world okay
and you get a glimpse of a Hollywood
star and it makes you feel better okay
you could be a little a little child a
little Asian child with no possessions
and no money but you get a you see a
picture of Angelina Jolie and you think
mummy foreign